bonjour à tous bonjour à tous je vais
lancer le live excusez moi
ok vous m'entendez c'est parfait
alors comme d'habitude au début vous
savez que je prends un petit peu de
temps pour l'installation je suis une
vieille personne
mais je vais vous laisser le temps
d'arriver
si vous vous êtes sur youtube pour la
redif ou fera re div switch bienvenue à
tous
au départ vous pourrez je pense
s'avancer je vais vous donner le le
thème las pour elle et dès le début
comme vous conviendra à ces deux les
gens sur le stream je vous laisse à tous
le temps de vous installer
salut thomas kso bas merci pour ton pour
ton passage bonne année à toi aussi
prends soin de toi prends soin de tes
poches de thé proche parent non pas de
tes proches et on se dira tout bientôt
la tablette
est surtout un bruit l'arrière scène les
petits qui miaule vous avez l'habitude
maintenant avec mes trois chats
je vais vous la porte
bonjour à tous a carrément fur et à
mesure que j'utilisais on est un petit
peu de temps au départ pour qu'on ne
puisse installer vous pouvez si vous
voulez tester les commandes alors on a
toujours
la commande player qui vous permet de
savoir
de qui on parle vous avez la commande
site pour avoir notre site envergure
toujours avec les nouveaux articles et
nouveau scouting répondre on a pu
diffuser depuis la dernière fois qu'on
s'est vus vous avez là comment de
twitter pour avoir les comptes twitter
d'envergure et mon compte twitter perso
si jamais ça vous intéresse par exemple
vous pouvez raté détruites hyper
intéressant comme moi qui crie devant le
buzzer beater 2 démarre dès roseanne qui
n'en revient pas de ce que fait monsieur
démarre des roses à ces derniers tentent
et puis voilà tout simplement tout
simplement
allez on va on va démarrer donc
déjà bonne année à tous prenez soin de
vous je vous souhaite le meilleur pour
cette année 2022 que ce soit du côté
personnel professionnel dans votre
famille dans votre vie privée peu
importe que du bonheur surtout prenez
surtout soin de vous faites attention à
vous et puis j'espère que votre équipe
nba favorite choisira un bon prospects
et on est la pompe à lesdins qui me
plaît particulièrement aujourd'hui il
s'appelle d'ayreon cibone donc des
récits bonne c'est un ailier qui joue du
côté de north carolina north carolina
state pour les wolf pack fac dont vous
avez peut-être entendu parler ces
dernières années avec un certain dennis
miss du new york est ressorti en loterie
alors derrière une si brawn pour
l'instant on en parle très peu si vous
avez vu notre live sur youtube où on a
parlé de notre board on a annoncé nos
board
du coup vous avez pu voir que je le cite
est comme joueur
comme joueur devra suivre un petit peu
sous les radars bien vu qu'un cas de noé
vont aller à toi aussi kamagaté au sein
de mon rêve fait pas je te le souhaite
je souhaiterais vraiment une super
pioche pour pour phoenix mail kamagaté
une très bonne et du côté du paris
basket j'ai eu la chance de voir en
braille qui a été très très
impressionnant contre l'asvel mais là
aujourd'hui deruns bonne je vais vous
mettre sa petite fiche
statistique et puis on fera comme
d'habitude un petit sommaire alors hop
on passe là dessus
on passe là dessus normalement ça doit
s'afficher à l'écran
vous n'hésitez pas à me dire si le son
est pas bon s'il ne l'avait pas bon
alors on a des pubs si jamais vous êtes
un pantalon aussi ici moi ce qui va
m'intéresser c'est ça donc des 26 bonnes
il est considéré comme un garde par
parler basket ball wii financiers et par
une spin et cetera mois plus tôt un
ailier à terme on a 2 m 01 81 kg donc un
grand porteur de balle faute à qui le
garde ses pairs sophomore vous voyez il
ya 38 matchs en tournée cette année
quatorze matches pour aller dans les
stats un petit peu classique les stats
brut vous voyez que l'an dernier il
jouait très peu mon première année 17
minutes seulement nous sortait du banc
avec 5,2 points cette année y ait une
explosion cette statistique il est
titulaire indiscutable
36,6 minutes sur 40000 de possibles qui
joue quasiment tout le match
pour à peu près 20 points de moyenne
donc un joueur qui est très efficace un
joueur qui part qui va marquer beaucoup
de points avec ça on nous trouve aussi
quasiment 10 rebonds toujours cette
répartition deux tiers à thiers ont fait
aussi le défensif on a trois passes
décisives et on voit trois pertes de
balle donc c'est pas un joueur qui fait
très attention ballon pour le moment ça
joue encore rester brut on va pouvoir
avoir tant dans les textes vidéos c'est
un joueur qui va provoquer beaucoup de
lancers francs on voit ça il en prend
plus de 6 par match quasiment 7 par
match avec une réussite moyenne à 70 %
ce qui est correct sans être
exceptionnelle
en termes de volume attendre de
répartition voit que sa joie qui ont
beaucoup de deux points on va voir que
c'est beaucoup de prix du panier
60% de réussite environ ce qui est assez
intéressant et un joueur qui prend un
tout petit volume à trois points et qui
est pas du tout est reçue en efficacité
voilà ça c'est pour les stades à peu
près brut hier soir il a joué contre
florida state donc les séminoles fac que
maintenant que vous connaissez bien qui
a sorti plusieurs joueurs draftés très
haut ces dernières années comme ce qu au
liban comme patrick williams comme
je parraine un peu ternes sman
une fin du cab nguele et cetera et
cetera donc programme donc à ses côtés
et donc il a joué contre eux et avec
leurs amis 32 points je me suis dit bon
allez c'est le moment c'est le début de
l'année ces deux nouvelles années
faisons faisons partager aux gens mon
petit coup de coeur nouvelle advance est
bonne on va aller sur les stades avancés
vous n'avez l'habitude on a regardé le
profil brute tombe sur les stades
avancés avec deux sites avant de passer
à la vidéo en même temps sur les réseaux
de twitter envergure excusez moi
j'essaie de tout soutien de tout gérer
en même temps
alors hop alors pourrait s'avancer on
utilise deux sites sap a changé entre
2021 et 2022 est sur les mêmes bases
des once est bonne vous l'avez l'a donc
la voiture matt vrai que je crée la
commande d'ailleurs ce match peut
essayer de vous le mettre dans les liens
du chat je vous mets ça tout de suite
pendant que vous pouvez commencer à
regarder la ligne de notre ami si brown
alors moi elsie state
ici donc en ce match un site qui vous
donne les
statistiques de
chaque joueur de l'équipe
donc vous l'avez leroy et statistiques
chaque jour de l'équipe en fonction des
compartiments du terrain dont vous avez
les tiers près du cercle la quantité le
pourcentage de tirs pris près du cercle
l'efficacité dans ce dans ce secteur et
enfin est ce que le fait de tissu ou non
d'une passe décisive vous avez la même
chose pour les deux points l'on appelle
le midway nage et enfin pour le tir à
trois points et puis parce que j'aime
bien vous avez la proportion de lancers
francs tentés par rapport aux nombres de
faire tomber vous voyez que cibone c'est
le leader au pont s'il est faible équipe
c'est celui qui prend le plus de tirs
avec une répartition de la tacc qui est
répartie majoritairement sur quatre
joueurs lui c'est un joueur qui va
prendre presque tous ces paniers près du
cercle 83 % de ces tirs sont pris près
du cercle on a dit qu'il en comptait
toc toc toc on a oui voilà on a 13 tirs
par match dont 80% si je dis pas trop de
bêtises et ça fait à peu près neuf tirs
pris près du panier et eva près du
panier il va trouver des lancers francs
9 tirs près du panier six lancers francs
tentés donc on retrouve là avec ce 46 %
ce qui est un pourcentage très
impressionnant à jour très agressif près
du cercle il y est assez efficace 59% on
n'est pas dans le top tiers d'un vus
plusieurs fois ensemble sur des stream
des joueurs à 70 75 80 % et 60 % c'est
quand même une belle efficacité pour
surtout un créateur qui ne qui génère
ses propres panier on voit que dans 75%
des cas
cibone secret son accès au panier très
peu de mi distance voilà vous voyez 6,2
pour cent avec une très mauvaise
efficacité 18% très peu de trois points
et encore une fois avec une mauvaise
efficacité même si du catch and shoot
uniquement dans ce secteur là donc
qu'est ce que nous disent les stats si
on découvre le joueur qu'on a un
agresseur de cercle majoritairement
et quasiment uniquement d'accord qui va
vraiment à slasher comme on en trouve
dans les années 2000 qui est très très
intéressant alors je ne sais pas si vous
êtes toujours là ou pas aussi ça un peu
planté donc c'est bon j'ai un petit lac
jour mon retour vous n'hésitez pas à me
dire si tout fonctionne bien ou pas on
va utiliser un deuxième site pour
confirmer ça que j'aime bien qui
s'appelle coupe explorer qui est notre
autre site qui fait de la d'analysé
stats initié
avec un code couleur donc on retrouve
les mêmes pourcentages ce que j'aime
bien voir ici c'est de voir que c'est un
joueur qui est efficace
plus efficace que la moyenne ainsi y ait
dans l'ue de points avec notamment 1 61%
près du panier donc ça c'est où il est
en efficacité moyenne à toujours mettre
en perspective avec le fait que c'est
une date qui prend en compte les meneurs
les arrières les aider les éleveurs et
les pivots et que les intérieurs
globalement des stats près du cercle
plus élevé que des extérieurs donc la
zone en porteur de balle avait quitté
pour réussite intéressant de près du
panier et on voit aussi que dans les
stats de tir à mi-distance trois points
il est très faible par rapport au reste
de la ligue là où il excelle aussi séoul
a vus ensemble dans la capacité à
trouver des lancers-francs lorsqu'il va
au cirque vous avez ici le free to wait
qui vous donne un peu son corps une fois
le nombre de lancers tentés par rapport
au nombre de tirs tentés voilà ça c'est
pour les stats et on va pouvoir regarder
maintenant du film ensemble
comme d'habitude quand on fait du film
on regarde les points forts du joueur il
est point faible du joueur et on essaie
de regarder sa vitesse réelle est au
ralenti tout en
tout emballante priorisant donc on va
commencer par ce qu'il fait de très bien
et cinq d'entre elles billets et plus on
avancera raymond ce seront des choses
qu'il fait bien ou moins ce sont des
choses qui sont déterminantes pour
l'entraînement et levier voilà je vous
prépare la petite playlist qui est ici
alors hop on est bien d'autres envergure
on est assis one qui est là
on va pouvoir mettre ça ensemble donc
pareil si jamais
la la vitesse est trop rapides roland
quelle explication pas clair vous
n'hésitez pas à donner en retour moi je
suis là pour ça je suis là pour vous
faire découvrir ce joueur alors ça va
c'est tout en douceur cette fois ci j'ai
vérifié que la playlist et n'était pas
fort que tout contrairement à la
dernière fois où ça allait totalement
planté entre les vidéos qui était pas
dans l'ordre et la coupure de courant
qui nous avait interrompu - dans cette
fois ci on est tranquille alors son
plein écran
siboni pour cible numéro 1 ensi state là
on est face à ferrer la séduction m'a
dit hier soir et on va regarder d'abord
ce qui peut-être fait le mieux on est
jour de la transition en vitesse réelle
on est parti l'avait l'art en transition
drive magot je change de mains et je
vais au peigne fin tout en vitesse tout
en efficacité
nova un vrai agresseurs de cercle je
vous la remet en ralenti celles là y'a
pas grand chose à dire sur le clip c'est
vraiment une mauvaise défense a move
heroes repli de transition il va très
vite balle en main on rappelle de metz
0-1 tout qu'un grand porteur de balle
comme moi je les aime bien c'est pour ça
que j'ai le draft très loin au pied
ici il est la vitesse réelle
je peux changer de mains je peux partir
aussi finir fort où trouver une fois
donc vous voyez que en face de lui donc
là on est face à oklahoma state qui est
une équipe de l'epic twelve avec une
grosse densité physique les défenseurs
de steven sont pas habitués à voir un
mec de cette taille-là de cette taille
là pardon aller aussi vite et est aussi
fluide et c'est vraiment sa force
principale
donc
en 05 je change de mains en plus je
voulais remercier parce que c'est un peu
le bouquet donc regarde je pars main
gauche au départ je change de main
ici et je peux accélérer très vite et je
protège très bien moindre avec nous la
main qui ne porte pas le ballon et je
vais en agressivité près du panier
actions suivantes ont cela remet en
vitesse réelle
donc là vous allez avoir à peu près 5 10
clips où il va au cercle voilà que
j'aimerais vous montrer tout ce qui peut
faire mal au mas est vraiment insister
sur cette vitesse deux premiers pas
cette fluidité dans son dribble et 7
cette agressivité nous qu'il est là il y
remonte la balle il ya un écran et je
vais très vite au panier et j'utilise la
planche pour ne pas me faire contrer
donc c'est un joueur qui sait déjà
lire une défense
et qui fait utiliser sa longueur de bras
et son explosivité pour se protéger des
défenses en direct voit la
vitesse réelle ici réception de balle
écran et je vais au cercle et je finis
main gauche n'était pas fluide on se
marre fait
je pense que c'est le subtil jeu suit
donc là on va être sur le départ ma
gauche finition main gauche donc c'est
un joueur qui peut finir des deux mois
c'est un droitier qui peut finir dès
demain
sortie d'écran encore une fois mais face
à pure d'où il ya un écran je parle ma
gauche
encore une fois du contrôle dans le
petit périmètre où je la remets
cette fluidité dans les têtes des
placements cette fluidité dans les
petits périmètres pour pouvoir créer un
écart avec son défenseur d'un bon
premier pas derrière l'écran je parle ma
gauche regardez là comment ils changent
de direction pour s'écarter de très
bonnes williams ici
je suis ma gauche il ya le protecteur de
cercle la trêve nous il est un conte qui
est là je vais changer de direction
hop longueur de jambes
je vais m'écarter et je vais finir
en utilisant la planche ou encore une
fois sans pouvoir être défendu on parle
chez envergure si vous avez une autre
dernier stream de porteur de balle à
trois vitesses être capable d'aller vite
normalement lentement et de changer
cette vitesse pendant son drive lui peut
faire ça alors qu'il va très souvent
vite mais il avait cette capacité à
ralentir ou accélérer en pleine de la
drive en plus du fait de pouvoir changer
de main dans son dribble
pour pouvoir sacré année car tant qu'on
a important de bâle qui est déjà
assez
assez près assez matures alors extraits
suivants
ça plante pas ici
vous dites si vous m'entendez j'essaie
de réelles émotions enlevée en même
temps
qu'elle vous m'entendez donc c'est la
technique qui a encore coupé superbe
on va faire comme ça
bon pour l'instant on est en galère
technique c'est pas grave on pas
continuer
à animer cette manière là
ok pardon pour ça le pc est pas encore
optimale
on va relancer c'est pas grave on devait
être à peu près ici je pense
est-ce qu'on se l'est fait sûr
aucun donateur
donc voilà vous avez un pourtour de
balle comme je disais qu'ils fluide peut
changer de vitesse qui peut accélérer
qui peut ralentir qui peut changer
demain qui sait utiliser sa main qui ne
porte pas le ballon et la planche pour
se protéger après un rebond offensif
départ main gauche et finitions au
panier vous avez compris je vais pas
passer au ralenti tous les clips encore
une fois je pars ma gauche capable de
finir ma gauche et de trouver la faute
donc havrais slasher
là j'aime bien obstacles donc je suis là
on peut peut-être se le faire parce que
là on est sûr de la technicité
donc là on est ligne de fond je parlais
à gauche on est face à nebraska match
absolument incroyable qui vante
quadruple propos prolongation avec à la
fin une victoire pour north carolina
state en face vous avez bryce mcgowan ce
qui est attendu au premier tour donc
matière à regarder si vous avez une
journée devant vous - gauche rap step
et on finit main droite et on va trouver
la faute donc si on se remet vitesse
réelle
donc des skills de garde pour un mec de
2 m toujours très intéressant notre
action
six toros step et je termine encore on
va avoir un deuxième gros step ici même
match
voilà c'est un joueur qui a des très
bons appuis on a vu la longueur leïla
c'est moi je sors pick'n roll capacité à
split et une défense alors on voit que
la trappe elle est assez faible par les
joueurs de nebraska elle n'est pas
franche donc juste plit la défense et je
vais finir au cercle et trouver la faute
donc la trouve la faute ici
on regarde pick and roll la défense me
trappe jeu split dans l'intervalle pape
d'accélérer
j'évite le bright mcguinty qui tentent
de provoquer un passage en force
et je vais trouver un panier facile avec
la voûte
là on est face à louisiana tech alors
l'usada tech sont dans leur équipe
petite pause il ya un joueur ici qui
s'appelle can has left and junior qui
est un jeune qui a gagné l'or avec
l'équipe américaine u19 cet été qui a
beaucoup fait parler de lui pour ses
physique un peu surprenant un joueur qui
est très massif avec une très belle
mobilité donc voilà à surveiller ce jour
là c'est pas juste un physique a même
sur internet c'est un vrai basketteur
dont on entendra parler dans les
prochaines années kenneth l'aftam junior
et j'ai fermé la parenthèse en
transition je change de dribble alors là
il y en avait peut-être trop vite
chiant x 2 et a passé vite que ça quand
même
en transition je change de mains pour
casser le rythme et je rechange de magne
troisième fois et je finis au pays
encore une transition
alors là il fan de hands off et je ré
accélèrent pour aller finir bout la
finition
est raté mais encore une fois un joueur
qui peut changer de vitesse qui peut
changer de rythme regardez ici
on va aller feinte et le hand of on
appelle donc cette situation de ma maman
avec l oms je feinte et je ré accélèrent
et j'attaque le cercle
super mauvais finition à 50 centimes
encore cet hymne de fond et je vais
trouver un panier près du cerveau là
vous l'avez compris au slasher je laisse
un petit peu défilé jusqu'au moment on
passe à une autre catégorie
et donc si bonne c'est un jour dont moi
j'avais pas du tout entendu parler l'an
dernier et qui cette année alors voilà
on est passé à cannes émission qui cette
année se révéler pour l'instant comme je
le disais j'en ai vus j'ai vu son nom
nulle part je suis assez surpris
j'ai vu son nom de nulle part parce
qu'un porteur de balle comme ça si grand
si rapides et si puissant normalement ça
intrigue beaucoup
les scouts un peu un peu reconnu et là
j'en ai pas entendu parler donc j'espère
que
déjà d'une part avant de confirmer si
oui ou non le jour et vous plaît
j'espère que je me fais pas de est une
mauvaise image de ces deux gars là et
que je suis seul à triper dessus mais
mais voilà un joueur un petit peu qui
passe sous les radars jour un pisteur
donc ici on a une situation de drive and
click on voit que c'est un joueur qui
peut forcément créé pour lui mais on a
vu trois passes décisives par match donc
aujourd'hui la situation de drague je
peux trouver mon coéquipier dans le
corner pour un drive in qui calera nba
ce foot là il rentrera il n'a pas des
coéquipiers n'ont plus de niveau
supérieur à notre driving quitte cette
fois-ci ma gauche à demain alors vous
avez vu comparé main droite on peut
passer à une main compare ma gauche on
passe à demain ce n'est pas encore un
passeur capable de
d'effectuer des passes à une machine à
faible ça fera le travail et au niveau
supérieur
ici je feinte la prise de pitié drôle je
change de dribbler jeu qui qu'encore une
fois côté ma gauche à demain maintenant
sur pick'n roll je peux trouver une
passe par dessus comme je suis très très
grand plus grand qu'un porteur de balle
classique combat seul à remettre là
alors effectivement elle a comme je suis
plus grand cas porteur de balle celle ci
que je peux trouver une passe par dessus
la défense est ce qu'on fait si avec lui
donna thècle on frise ici nokia un écran
can has left and junior est par ailleurs
très mobile à l'intérieur qui va rouler
au panier
l'intérieur ou ne roule pas franchement
au cercle donc on temporise
et la passe par dessus le défenseur
parma longueur alors l'envergure je les
ai pas exactement là pas été mesuré elle
est estimée aux alentours de 2 mai 08
2010 à peu près
pour un jour qui on le rappelle fait de
mettre zéro nouvelle capable de passer
et chant pick and roll par dessus
capable aussi de passer voilà un point
tout simplement une passe à une main
directe alors cela remet au ralenti
pick and roll mauvaise lecture de la
défense et je passe à une main pour mon
joueur qui roule
encore une passe par dessus vous voyez
que c'est un joueur qui n'est pas
initialement un honneur pure mais c'est
très bien capable de pouvoir jouer sur
drive in teak sur pick'n roll au niveau
supérieur
encore un pick and roll
alors là on voit maintenant les
difficultés qui va peut-être avoir
c'est qu'il va pouvoir raté des passes
ici notamment sur transition on a
quelque chose d'encore très perfectible
alors bon c'est pas de chance qu'il plat
que je voulais aller
ici donc on est sûr transition vous
allez voir qu'il ya deux coéquipiers qui
sont totalement ouverts les cibles one a
encore un peu le problème tunnel vision
donc là on archi teurs qui peut aller se
décaler dans le corner qui totalement
ouvert il le rate il préfère attaquer le
cercle parce que c'est un agresseur à
slasher en arène deuxième shooter ici
helens dans le corner gauche qui est
ouvert et je vais m'en foncé sur une
défense
je trouve une faute mais j'ai quand même
des possibilités ou plus
optimale là on a un joueur qui va aussi
l'a vu perdre trois ballons par match
quasiment parce qu'il chante tente des
choses très difficiles ces problèmes des
dribbleurs qui sont très à l'aise dans
le rôle dans leur haendel ce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils peuvent se sortir de
toutes les situations et des fois y'a
voilà on reconnaît pas la situation de
trappe et je perds le ballon ça fera le
travail et c'est un joueur qui en
manquent encore de propreté
je crois qu'on est sûr transition encore
une fois qu'on va rater une passe au
regard de sa non alors l autre problème
de ces bonnes on l'a vu dans les stats
c'est que c'est un joueur qui
n'est pas efficace à trois points qui
comprend très très peu et du coup les
défenses elle s'adapte donc là vous avez
c'est le troisième la troisième
prolongation donc les bras ce cas a eu
tout le loisir du monde de s'adapter ils
ont compris que c'est un joueur qui
aimait aller au panier et du coup vous
pouvez regarder comment la défense elle
va être campé à l'intérieur quand il
affronte
alors ici
avec le défenseur lui donne quasiment
deux mètres d'écart et va protéger son
cercle parce que lui il n'y aura pas
pendant son dribble prenante ou l'appât
trois points il le fera pas donc ils
préfèrent s'avancer et attaquer le
cercle est si profond provoque un
passage en force
autre situation la défense reste bien à
l'intérieur on n'a pas le cloud ne sert
à rien il n'a pas être une menace il ya
un écran on reste loin et du coup il
prend un tir à trois points il le rate
parce qu'il n'est pas encore à l'aise là
dessus c'est un peu le syndrome russell
westbrook on a un joueur qui n'est pas
respectée sur son tir pour l'instant à
juste titre et avec défense qui s'adapte
et qui vont du coup lui laisser beaucoup
de beaucoup de marche pas dessus
on sait qu'en nba les premières années
tout du moins la première année les
équipes en face à s'adapte pas donc
ciboure et normalement il n'y aura pas
ce genre de défense la crise rares
outils et il va falloir travailler sur
le tir pour pouvoir exister on sait que
maintenant un porteur de balle un ailier
qui shoote pas
il a des difficultés à rester sur le
terrain donc faudra développer ça
ici à vitesse réelle
catch and shoot
donc
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que si il
en prend pas beaucoup quand il est en
situation de la corne avant catch and
shoot y en a de plus en plus et commence
à remettre je trouve que le geste est
plutôt fluide on regarde les mâles sont
prêtes vitesse d'exécution c'est assez
rapide le geste est assez propre et sa
renault qu'on a je vous ai pris trois
séquences de catch and shoot
dans le corner je ne recule d'un pas et
je déclenche et 3e situation toujours
dans le corner mais ma sont prêtes le
geste est rapide et je suis en
efficacité donc voilà pour le moment un
volume très faible une réussite qui ont
la vue n'est pas au rendez vous mais la
gestuelle la mécanique et le fait de
plus en plus les prendre sur des
situations des renversements dans des
corners me font penser 4 terme
notre ami silwan pourrait être un tireur
alors je parle pas d'un shooter sniper à
40% mais quelque chose d'assez honnête
pour être respecté on a une bille est
pour le moment
s'ils tirent ils sont pas pris dans la
dans un décalage pas la main ils t'ont
pas pris of the jewel on n'a pas un
joueur qui va créer des step back
qui va faire des failles steve voilà qui
va prendre des poules up on est vraiment
sur soi je vais au cercle soit je suis
du catch and shoot donc pour la
polyvalence dans le jeu on n'est pas sur
quelque chose de supérieur mais ce
premier pas cette taille cette
agressivité ce dribble le font quand
même acheter un autre
maintenant votre situation ou cibone
peut exister ce jour du vote donc du
démarquage
loin du ballon voilà ici je lis la
défense et je vais du coup sûr une
situation de cut me rendre disponible
pour finir près du panier ça aussi en
biya à côté d'un premier pourtant de
balle dans mes mains deuxième poteau de
bâle i peut
avoir un rôle il ya un manque de
verticalité de détente sèche qui me pose
un peu problème pour un athlète et le
billet c'est pas non plus du niveau dans
six journées exemple de mecs qui saute
pas d'un vieux temps genting par exemple
on a quand même fait correct mais voilà
c'est pas non plus un ken talbot and que
vous pouvez renoncer dans cette cuvée
qui montre très haut les plus sûrs du
standing d'un
paolo bonne quéro quittant une bonne
athlète mais qui n'est pas non plus un
athlète qui perdent mais non
là on le voit justement face à une
équipe ultra de l'équipe d'oklahoma
state se faire prendre parce qu'il n'est
pas ils montent pas au dessus de tout le
monde
on va passer en défense alors là je
préfère prévenir avant de commencer
c'est un joueur qui défend très peu à
l'image de nc state et c'est la fête ne
te de loups ne défend pas et si bonne et
très frustrante de choses qu'on va
pouvoir observer premièrement en manque
de vous monter et deuxièmement une
limitation latéral parce qu'il ya des
anges très très hot et vous le savez si
vous ne suivez depuis un petit peu de
temps que des joueurs
que des joueurs avec des hanches très
haute ou du mal sur les rotations sur
les changements d'appuis et peuvent se
faire déposer comme ça on n'a pas à
l'est déjà pour déjà barry smith lui il
peut avoir le même problème
alors nous et je trouve le gan nulle
part sur les boîtes américaines à des
bons flashs pourtant ouais tu vois on
n'en parle pas du tout parce que c'est
un joueur qui jouait pas l'an dernier
c'est pas une énorme recrues je pense
que c'est une recrue 4 étoiles seulement
et c'est une équipe et un système qui
est pas hyper flashy il avait un très
bon pivot qui s'appelle manech many many
je sais plus mali bates qui est un
énorme contraire qui est blessé pour la
saison donc je pense que c'est pâques à
une équipe qui est très suivie et
pourtant le joueur fait des grosses
performante alors là ils sont sur une
série de cinq défaites de suite ce qui
va pas arranger le cas de déduire une si
bonne mais peut-être qu'un match comme
celui contre florida state qui comporte
plusieurs prospects et le billet qu'une
équipe très très en vue le fera monter
aux yeux des des scouts
décevoir de ce coûteux américain des
scouts de droite etc donc c'est à
surveiller faut savoir aussi que quand
vous regardez des modes draft sur des
grands sites classiques et un consensus
qui a un peu fait monde se copier à peu
près
et c'est pas forcément les les mots-clés
plus les plus pertinentes quoi on suit
beaucoup à des consignes shakespearienne
entre autres pour faire des mots qu'un
peu consensuel et retrouver les mêmes
noms et créer et créent des et du
storytelling
donc voilà là défensivement on l'a dit
problème dans vie vous voyez il laisse
complètement son joueur se démarquait
nous glisse il a de la chance ça ne crée
pas un panier
pour l'attack donc il est en couverture
de bryce mcgowan ce qui est là
il est très nonchalant et du voilà
couvre le moi je m'en occupe pas je rêve
près du ballon et on aurait pu avoir un
décalage pour un tiers à droite
ici ils laissent passer
donc mais au ralenti
voilà une première accélération de
brasse maïwenn qui fait pas d'effort il
trottine près du cercle il laisse passer
autre situation ici l'an couverture
change 55 stefanovic qui est un
excellent tireur
pas focus du tout il est stephano beach
et des marcaires juste aura 40% et ça
fait ficelle
ici on est chauds du repli
et vous voyez là c'est plus un problème
physique problèmes de hanches que sur du
changement de direction par un porteur
de balle par un garde je peux me faire
des pauses et donc il prend position il
anticipe un départ à gauche changement
de direction à droite il est passé donc
là des bonnes mans ensuite pour essayer
de de volée le ballon vous avez
peut-être pu voir dans les stades tout à
l'heure on est à une verrue six tirs par
match donc ça jure qu'ils interceptent
pas mal le ballon plus parce que il
m'aider il a des longs brahim et des
couches les moins quand il fait passer
on essaie de voler la balle plutôt qu'en
mettant une répression défensif
ici que là aux hot et je suis en
difficulté encore une fois latéralement
sur un jour plus petit donc là
sur le tranquille est ici
voilà jusque là zot feinte première
accélération il se fait prendre dans le
vent vous voyez ici il y avait un petit
récap de stats toujours café le plus de
double double en début de saison dans la
lcf qui est une amie joy un des joueurs
qui prend le plus de rebonds alors que
c'est incarne ce joueur qui prenait à ce
moment là trois interceptions par match
alors ça réagit maintenant si ça s'est
un peu calmé depuis cinq six matches et
un des joueurs les plus efficaces
de sa conférence en termes de
pourcentage global
alors ici on la retrouve là
défensivement je pense que sans qu'un
changement de rythme en changement de
direction d'un changement de direction
mais je fais un effort latéralement à
cette fois ci je conteste alors je me
fais prendre
c'est un joueur qui devrait pour moi en
nba tenir des ailiers uniquement et qui
sur switch devra orienter alors pourquoi
ça se passe mieux c'est comme il est
long
sur des courses
unidimensionnel sur des courses on ne va
pas avoir de changement
demain de changement de direction il va
pouvoir tenir une courbe
à une courbe com - deere courbe est
linéaire si je peux me permettre il va
de plus en
facilité donc là vous voyez au niveau de
la puce je change d'appui et je vais
juste contesté latéralement sur ma
gauche un coup à droite sur ma droite le
porteur de balle is it ne changera pas
de direction que nous pour lui c'est
beaucoup plus facile je tiens et ça fait
une bonne défense peut capter le rebond
et partir en transition
par elle il y avait hier plus d'efforts
défensivement à jouer encore une fois
que ne peut pas voir ce texte qui ne
peut pas changer de direction et donc je
peux leur côté à latéralement c'est pour
ça que je le vois plus sur l ailier
qui n'est pas qui sera moins à l'aise
dans le porter de balkh sur ont vraiment
des extérieurs ici on va on a dit qu'ils
et elles ont donc transition et ensuite
tu peux mener juste donc j'ai intercepte
le ballon peut mener la transition je
trouve une bonne passe et un panier
facile donc la pam à longueur j'ai
intercepter la balle je contrôle bien
loin de rible je vois mon coéquipier
devant et lui transmet le ballon mon
coéquipier et un étang un pitre rate le
lay up et par mes qualités athlétiques
je suis bien la balle jusqu'au bout et
je peux sur un rebond offensif terminer
comme ça
voilà et on a fait le tour
pour résumer si dwan c'est donc un
ailier pour moi en nba qui jouera post3
poste 4 qui va mettre un peu plus de
poids sur je voulais ça tournait en
boucle en attendant qu à mettre un peu
plus de poids du coup jour ce corps là
il est qu'à 81 kg qui sera dans un rôle
de second porteur de balle d'une équipe
d'agresseurs de panique y trouvera des
lancers francs dans un rôle à la pascal
siakam peut-être un rôle similaire je le
vois bien du co exister comme je le dis
avec un meilleur à meilleur porteur de
balle à côté de lui je le draft pour ses
qualités de premiers pas de dribble
deux finitions en loterie
voilà dans le temps ce que je vais
l'avoir à peu près 10 11 12 dans la fin
de ma loterie mais en loterie quand même
faudra lui donner du temps
pour développer un tir mais je pense
qu'on peut mettre du shoot sur ce joueur
plutôt sur des situations de catch and
shoot que mon choix du pool up
défensivement faudra faire plus
d'efforts mais le fait de le mettre en
défense sur des ailiers sont moins à
l'aise sur des champions du dribble en
feront peut-être un défenseur plus
correct
maintenant il ya un manque de
concentration qu'on lui pardonnera pas
il faudra travailler dessus mais c'est
pas le premier joueur qui fait peu
d'efforts ont essayé avec lequel tu
athlétique et qui ensuite de liens
défenseur correct en nba on voit anthony
edwards si en foot est pas une du côté
de georgia qui cette année a montré des
efforts est capable de faire au moins
les minima pour il utiliser son corps
pour pouvoir tenir
son en attaquant sur le ballon loin du
ballon et ne pas être un boulet pour son
équipe voilà le dernier mot nagge dites
ce que vous en pensez 6 un jour qu'il
vous plaît ou pas j'espère que vous avez
fait découvrir à un profil pour
l'instant méconnue
suivez ce gars il est hyper intéressant
il ya un match que je vous ai dit contre
florida state où il met 16 points hier
en première mi temps
sauf à cette bonne équipe défensive à
regarder si vous avez l'occasion et puis
et puis voilà ce sera un joueur je pense
qu'ils devraient qui devrait se
présenter à la draft d'années parce
qu'il aura
je pense qu'il aura une bonne cote et
qui pourrait se faire prendre
au premier tour et proment l'autre hic
ouais c'est vraiment dommage de ne pas
faire la défense les efforts
défensivement bah ouais je suis bien
d'accord suis toujours frustré de toute
façon quand je regarde un joueur
un joueur avec des qualités athlétiques
très souvent je me dis j'espère qu'il
fait les efforts défensivement et très
souvent il les fait pas moffett
finalement c'est que c'est pas un bel
athlète lui il a les capacités
athlétiques pour le faire mais voilà il
ya un manque à mon goût d'efforts
mais voilà qu'on est pas encore une fois
c'est pas le premier ce sera pas le
dernier et cd mais qu' il ya des mecs
comme ça qui une fois qu'ils arrivent au
niveau pro qui sont plus les stars de
leurs équipes vont s'y mettre là son
équipe a les jours cinq défaites
d'affilée parce qu'ils sont pas foutus
de défendre sur des matchs sur des
matchs serrés mais c'est toute l'équipe
pensait pas que lui j'espère qu'on est
vers une remise en question et que le
coach va mettre des tatanes parce que
c'est juste très frustrant
à regarder
il a l'air bon pique dit c'est peut-être
un peu comme au premier tour c'est grave
possible mais après voilà pouvoir qu'ils
ont mais dans sa loterie - là pour
l'instant je fais une loterie au monde 6
h compte pas la nba lé l'europe et la
g-league parce que je les ai moins en
vue j'ai pour l'instant que de trois
matchs de ces compétitions là donc faire
pas les classes et on est sur une draft
on l'a peut-être déjà dit sur envergure
qui a pas de beaucoup de potentiel
extraordinaire voilà on n'a pas une
grosse densité de deux joueurs deux
joueurs qui pourraient dominer au niveau
supérieur donc assez rapidement on
revient sur des profils de joueurs là
des sophomores qui explose cette année
salut je sillonne ouais ouais ça va bien
j'espère que ça va être une belle année
aussi on parlait de delvin simoneau
qu'on a fini le clip sur ce joueur et
puis
de toute façon il y aura le replay ce
qui sera sur la chaîne switch et sur
youtube si vous avez raté le si vous
avez raté le live stojakovic ses points
forts c'est important de balle de 2 m 01
donc ça ça fait toujours me fait
toujours fantasmer personnellement en
tant que scout amateurs qui est un très
bon premier pas qui est capable de
partir sur les demain main gauche main
droite qui est capable de finir avec les
deux mains gauches ma droite c'est un
droitier de base qui peut changer de
vitesse qui peut accélérer qui peut
ralentir pendant son horrible qui peut
changer demain pendant son dribble
équipe s'est adapté son geste en l'air
et qui cellectis bien la planche c'est
un passeur correcte sans être un passeur
supérieur c'est plus un deuxième porteur
de balle
et c'est un défenseur qui a des qualités
des outils pour défendre des ailiers à
ce qu'il est puissant parce qu'il est
grand parce qu'il est long mais qui en
difficulté latéralement à cause des
hanches hôtes et qui fait pas beaucoup
d'efforts à l'image de son équipe qui en
fou pas une voilà c'est pas que je t'ai
faire un petit un petit bilan complet
petit tu leur galette du clip au ralenti
avec de l'analyse un peu précise ce toit
yahoo
ou autre il ya le le replay qui sera sur
la chaîne twitch
jeu si on peut s'abonner maintenant
effectivement effectivement
envergure est devenu affiliés twitch ça
ne rigole plus on a on a passé assez de
temps en temps pour devenir
faut devenir affiliés tweet ça veut dire
qu'on a débloqué les abonnements pour
ceux qui connaissent pas le principe des
abonnements si vous n'êtes pas des
habitués de la plateforme vous pouvez
soutenir financièrement
envergure ça coûte je crois 4 euros par
mois pour tous les abonnements ou bien
utilisez votre abonnement offert amazon
prime ça nous permet de nous faire un
peu de revenus sur la sur la chaîne et
pouvoir nous équiper maintenant rien
d'obligatoire je suis pas je vous avoue
que j'en ai même pas parlé c'est
disponible mais
voilà c'est si seulement vous en avez
envie et les moyens de la possibilité
mais on est juste là d'abord pour qu'il
fait ensemble il n'y a pas un objectif
de devenir milliardaire
avec avec le streaming vous inquiétez
pas bah écoutez je vous propose de
prendre des questions si vous n'avez
j'attends les 'big board' bas on a fait
un live youtube n'y a pas très longtemps
juppé c'est de mettre le lien ici
on va
remettre ça pour l'instant je peux vous
faire un petit coucou rapidement
regarder à observer n'y fit coucou j'ai
ma veste chicago j'ai mon maillot
d'église rien ne va les cheveux c'est
une n'importe quoi bonne année à tous et
il faudra ça c'est dégueulasse je vais
aller c'est le logo regard dur qui bien
que flux
esthétique et je vous mets le lien
de youtube on parle de nos tiers de nos
trois premiers tirs avec alan alain
guillou avec roman qui est l'assistant
coach de strasbourg et membre envergure
depuis la première heure et alexandre du
papa d'envergure on vous a donné nous
voilà nous nous nous joueurs principaux
et sur le site internet on devrait
pouvoir le mettre assez saman sous peu
dès que antoine qui gère le site aura
aura le temps pour pouvoir nous mettre
ça en il met près je peux vous donner
globalement mon top au top 14 pour les
fans de rugby
à merci beaucoup je steagal c'est hyper
gentil tu apparemment c'est très très
très gentil ta part merci beaucoup
à la sas et le lien pour regarder la
vidéo où on parle de nos classements si
j'avoue donné mon top 14 à peu près en
gros on peut retrouver pas l'aubaine
cadeau on peut retrouver jason owen
jabbari smith jaden ivy kendall boyne
diwan si bonne
qu'ils jean bottes le de florida state
dont personne ne parle pour l'instant
aussi tout qui est ce que j'ai encore
gender and que je vais quand même gardé
malgré des doutes que je peux avoir
faudrait que l'on retrouve sous les yeux
là je vais pas particulièrement comme ça
et jean guy finn devrait se trouver à
terme qu'elle est bloch voit l'année on
vous mettra sa plus propre
plus proprement sur sur le site
envergure je vous propose on se fait un
petit jeu ensemble et on s'arrête là on
va se faire un petit ou à s'en faire une
petite draft on va essayer de repartir
de la dernière fois on va prendre la
draft
2020 et on va essayer de leur faire on
sent bon quiz si vous avez envie
de le faire avec moi je vous balance le
liant
dans le nom le chat
on a 60 joueurs à trouver alors attendez
je vous trouve ça je vous trouve ça ici
homme joue messala
60 joueurs à trouver de la draft 2020
hop
avec
l'équipe qui l'a drafté initialement
donc ça prend pas en compte
ça prend pas en compte les transferts
est aussi la leur provenance donc
l'université alors c'est quoi oui je
veux juste faire un quiz inquiète pas ça
va bien se passer
oui
merci
incroyable formidable
donc je vous balance ça donc j'ai pris
ce lien là
si vous avez envie qu'on le fasse
ensemble je vais faire un petit hammer
voilà si vous voulez pas vous faire
spoiler
vous couper le son et puis on a douze
minutes je pense qu'on va essayer de
faire ça dans les temps s'ils n'ont
trouvé au moins 50 ne serait pas mal et
on se revoit on se retrouve à la fin ale
dee timer 5 4 3 2 1 et c'est parti
alors le premier choix de la draft on en
a parlé juste avant plus c'est bon
deuxième choix j'espère qu'il va pouvoir
commencer à jouer tout bientôt
ensuite le troisième choix
moi j'ai son frère dans mon équipe
4e combat pour le coup lui joue chez moi
nous voilà le 5e c'était mon coup de
coeur
j'espère qu'avec les blessures il pour
avoir du temps de jeu le sixième choix
alors lui on attend encore plus beaucoup
le voir aussi grosse blessure mais belle
mais vos bestiaux physique est-ce qu'on
a un article sur envergure qui explique
le fonctionnement de la n 6 et est
gardé dans l'est dans les archives c'est
possible qu'on est enfant on a sorti
beaucoup à moi même avant que j'arrive
dans l'équipe
faudra garder sinon pourra en faire un
jeu tout comme ça et on en a un qui doit
expliquer en tout cas le fonctionnement
des matchs de conférences et d'un lasse
pas de là c'est quasiment sûr
alors le pic 8 de dayton le
le stikeman ensuite pique neuf joueurs
qui est de plus en plus bon et qui se
régale du côté de washington on va
bientôt faire un stream dessus avec alan
d'une garde des sceaux 90 têtes les pics
10 alors il peut pas trop jouer le
pauvre c'est john smith un peu là le pic
que nous qui vient aussi de florida
state
saha joueurs qui auraient besoin d'en
avoir un love le pic 12
le pic 13 arrêts lui faudrait qu'ils
jouent c'est fou le nombre de joueurs
qui ont fait ce qu v qui n'ont pas
l'occasion de s'exprimer le pic 14
quand je vous parlais d'un jour qui
défend des peanuts en 6 et qui
maintenant défend un peu mieux en nba
avec des attributs athlétique monsieur
aouanès mais disposent là dans le genre
il faisait aucun effort du côté de
vanderbilt et samatan c'est un peu mieux
avec les celtics pic 16 notre ami qui
fait la bagarre avec lebron james que
j'ai donc dans mon coeur pas à lastours
pic 17 en un possible à écrire aussi ça
la jo je suis désolé tu as envie de me
tuer sûrement moi je l'appelle toujours
beaucoup dont je rêverais pas aller car
sinon c'est à l'orthographe merci tu me
régale non vraiment je triche pas mais
[Musique]
merci ensuite arizona donc lille pareil
il joue pas
villanova c'est notre amie
sadie vous j'ai trouvé comme celle 4
colorado même temps superbe pic vin
un peu la
can inquiète tout le meneur titulaire de
philadelphia qui l'aurait cru arizona le
jazzman
timide à faire de la musique new york
donc d'enzo
qui jouait du côté des new zeland
breakers
kentucky 25
le jour qui est plus rapide que son
nombre
26 qui avait surpris à l'époque et qui
montre pourquoi les seniors ont une
place en nba le pic suivant il avait
encore plus surpris
le coup pivot énorme de kansas
washington ici c'est un boost hills
la san diego state je pense que c'est
lui ok si sion ça énorme style si moi je
l'avais limite le tribord loterie
[Musique]
le pic trop terne qui n'a jamais joué en
nba qui a des problèmes parce qu'il
devra peut-être arrêté le basket c'est
dramatique
le petit de stanford ensuite duke c'est
un jour dans un derby en à nos deux
familles
minnesota 33 new york or il doit pas y
jouer lui a assez le pivot
donc je retrouverai plus tard je vois
très bien qui s'est
ensuite michigan state 34 du côté de
quoi de sacramento michigan state non
est ce que c'est un transfert fin non
michel gane stage et la honte
à notre ami oui mais voilà il ajouté lui
même fils du coup 37 hockey ici pour une
corde je l'aurais pas 38 fine c'est ça
ben syracuse 39
ah non
c'est pas comme ça non c'est pas
celui-là bon moi je n'aurais pas non
plus
mississippi state 40 et zef à selma
justement du côté de sacramento hyper
massif
je vais avoir oublié le nom si je suis
pas bon
41 celle-là kentucky
qui maintenant jeu du côté de des
hornets texas tech pour une garde donc
pareil côté de sacramento
le pivot monténégro donc qui joue chez
moi il a fait une année
oméga l'ex avant de revenir donc il
avait testé h 45 milwaukee elle fait un
bon début de saison sont pas passés le
coach du nigeria revoilà infos inutiles
portland oui c'est notre ami cjy
il sera l homme ils vont me tuer ils
vont me tuer il ya une propagande
comment il s'appelle merde
non j'oubliais la vesle retrouver après
ali vont me m'assassiner sont fans de
lui non plus
arizona du coup c'est l'italien qui est
une langue problème d'embolie pulmonaire
etc y retourner du côté de bologne
kansas philadelphia assez le shooter en
séries mais là j'ai un trou en revenir à
vraie poésie state
golden state non non plus houleux lors
il est pas bon
non plus à manassas ces cas sus
hockey brooklyn 55
charleston je vois que lui c'est non
comment il s'appelle
tant pis
jacques aubert l'a45 c'est pas bon 45
fait pas bon du tout alors il faut que
je retrouve les lunettes que joue qu'il
ya 8 10 6 pour louise évidemment ensuite
utah state 60 qui vient de jeter de
newton dans le secteur je crois
ça c'est comme un thriller du côté des
champs de clients c'est bon
un américain qui allait du côté du coup
qu'elle joue en australie un autre
nom je le dis johnston plus espacées de
rapts là
nous racontent n'importe quoi
maintenant le méga minnesota le pivot
avec les dreads comment il s'appelle à
il a été échangé
moi je retrouverai pense pas
non
eh ben je suis pas bon je suis pas bon
du tout
vous en avez trouvé
il reste trois minutes 23
mai s'appelle petites robes arkansas la
tutelle
adriano je crois ouais c'est ça rezaï
est choqué bien joué ensuite l essieu l
essieu les cieux nantes poésie non sais
pas qu'est ce qu'elle va devoir d'y
aller cette année
nous
ni 20 dans l'outback
mais si mes dents mais toi je t'ai
forcément skymiles et yale spin move
gaye skylands ok merci
buzy
non pas la mort stevens crise appelle la
grosse brute là est ce que vous l'avez
dans le cha cha la grosse brouille du
côté des quines ce qu'on aimerait bien
voir jouer il perd les appels à un vrai
slasher et jour ce pas son nom
je sais plus comment il s'appelle
ceux qui nous rejoignent on a fait le le
bois et donnent de défense est bonne un
ailier que je vois drafté au premier
tour en loterie du côté de m6 tête un
petit quizz pour finir le
le comme moyen pour finir lui le live
qu'on profite la draft 2020 et comme
vous le voyez chu assez assez moyen
assez moyens de viser 50 on a 49
j'en retrouve pas ce grand pivot la des
golden gophers
avec des dreads qui a vu une belle cote
et qui était descendu je ne retrouve pas
le l'ailier des messies peut-être le
gros le coût la grosse brute l'admet ce
type state syracuse c'est pas au chai
brissette
s'est pas tu as battle c'est pas cool
chic guerrier
je n'arrive pas à voir lequel c'est le
meneur qui jouent en australie côté
boston qui est six tâches madar
voilà les cinq ans tout assuré yamada
revoilà que que pierre adore dans
l'équipe envergure qu'il aimerait bien
voir revoir ici
ce pivot la mississippi state puis vous
je sais plus est ce qu'on n'a pas
giannone personne n'est pas mon ski est
là donc moi je vais je vais rezaï ne va
pas on va pas aller plus loin mais ça
plaît déjà c'est le pivot autour bah oui
alors vite crédit j'aurais jamais trouvé
il y déjà use effectivement robert
willard seconde de ces lieux chercher
j'ai simplement rappelle plus qui a dit
martin me rappelais plus jesse quoi vous
rappelle pas ouais jeep et j'aurais pu
le retrouver sa mairie le shooteur utah
state effectivement qui joue maintenant
je crois
du côté tonton et john darwin pareil je
me rappelais plus c'était dur j'ai fait
40 mais c'est déjà bien 40 ans moi je la
jette épique qui avec moi même me suis
échauffé en disant 50 mais le second
tour comme c'est des mecs ce vent qui
joue pas on peut regarder tes où il joue
pas car ils jouent pas au tour il joue
pas mal et dont il joue plus il manie
joue bay tiges pas il a été manager
chicago catchy coûte pas et il est ce
que ce public est très bas même si c'est
possible pour faire de la place à notre
oeil
à notre amitié lie c'est possible pour
37 way 37 pas mal pas mal déjà si vous
avez le premier tour c'est bien
franchement moi juge trop pitié avec
moi-même et et voilà très jones alors
lui joue pour le coin peu richard doux
parham ses joues pas si mon avis tu y
joues pas noir il joue les bayous
quasiment pas madar il est encore en
europe mais nous y retourner en europe
johnny joue pas mais il joue pas jessop
non plus martin je crois pas non plus
cash in sony joue pas stanley il joue
plus du tout nba ce creux bijoux pas
grand thriller il joue pas non plus eddy
ferhi il joue pas paul reed il a un peu
joué et à oui c'est mais willy joue pas
donc vous voyez c'est c'est normal et
c'est normal bon bah écoutez c'était
bien bien cool j'espérais passer un bon
moment je vous fait encore une une belle
année 2022 une réussite donc tous les
domaines comme vous le disait et puis je
vais vous laisser là si vous avez raté
ce live et que vous voulez voir le début
vous tous qui avez raté tout le début
comme je le disais il sera en replay sur
cette chaîne twitch il sera en replay
sûr sur youtube donc
donc voilà n'hésitez pas et puis on se
retrouve tous bientôt âgé dé le temps
des petits commentaires john marie l'un
de tes rapine c'est une petite équipe on
s'y met c'est une équipe de mise mais
dort donc c'est à dire qu'une conférence
moyenne c'était pas dans les six grosses
conférences mais c'est une équipe
reconnue les termes s'ils sont envoyés
des plusieurs joueurs en billets donc
notamment notre ami qui est là alors où
est ce qu'il est implicite jaden smith
qui est un vrai joueur et l'année
précédente et dans la vo co renvoyer un
je crois
en nba voilà c'est une équipe est
moyenne mais moyenne plus
isolé a pas mal qui joue pas on peut
regarder vite fait
mon lui tout le temps blessé mais ça
joue
tout tout tout tout à l'air d'écouter
des thérapies ne se retient une paire de
jumeaux intérieur assez intéressante
mais qui se développe pas comme on
aurait pu attendre mais je crois que
voilà il ya deux jumeaux sympa chez les
termes c'est les tortues donc ensuite à
gène smith du coup je vous parie
versions soient retransférés je pense à
la trade and line wasteels ajout
ali pardon ajoute ira lewis ça joue pas
suffisamment mais face aux new orleans
saints contexte horrible nesmith à joan
pawnee joue
stuart ça joue beaucoup beaucoup je sais
pas cette année joe aussi jouent
beaucoup ou pas ça se développe bien
pour lui chacune y joue pas mais se
passe que dallas fait un peu n'importe
quoi là dessus aussi alors que c'est un
vrai joueur en tout cas c'est un vrai ce
rien dit sadi qui joue bien précious
côté tonton je crois qu'il joue et
j'avais vu qui jouait sa en bon pivot
mobile tu as eu les deux titulaires zik
il joue pas mais il est trop fin mai 11
je fais confiance à
andenne vert pour développer parce qu'il
ya un vrai potentiel de 4,5 mobile
shooter mollema rouge crois pas que ça
joue ntone sajoo l'église joue prix de
chasse à juhasz du bic et ça joue pas
mis leur ai jamais dieu drafté cet
endroit là c'est une une incohérence
totale djeddah n'y joue malakai ils
jouent très très peu du côté de toronto
et desmond bensadoun grave donc ouais
franchement c'est pas mal c'est une
draft qui a ses diplômes role players on
leur fera un jour de façon très posé
tout ça mais n'en fasse eddie pons role
players mais oui forcément des mecs un
peu un peu plus inconnu où on va écouter
je vais vous laisser là je vous dis à
tout bientôt bon courage pour ceux qui
reprennent
les jours à l'école la fac le boulot si
vous étiez en vacances prenez soin de
vous et vous y êtes tous bientôt chez
cheikh envergure
vendredi on va reprendre les streams à
tous les vendredis de façon plus posée
avec alan où se retrouvent vendredi pour
faire du bois qu donne deux joueurs nba
et n'diaye et ensuite ma tous les autres
vendredi plus quelques petits jours par
ci par là qu'on a envie de se faire
kiffer voilà prenez soin de vous des
bisous et à la prochaine